[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about some of the main characters that
won't certainly face their end in the
fighting season in this video we'll be
introduced with the deaths of the
Lancers Jaime Tyrion and Cersei some of
these deaths are confirmed by a hundred
percent energy leaks and leaked photos
while some are only supported by Furies
of minds so let's just jump into it
let's start with the death of Jaime
Lannister whose end will be no other
than his sister and former lover herself
Cersei Lannister in the end of season
seven Jaime finally sees his sister for
what she really is an insane delusional
and power-hungry queen who will betray
anyone to secure her reign no matter if
your own life or the whole realm is in
danger
Jamie finally Benison sister to honour
and help the North Face the White
Walkers after healer in deserts in urine
plot to dishonour to choose between the
Iron Throne and the alliance of House
Targaryen and how start Jamie now rides
north but he will eventually be back at
King's Landing where he'll face death
queen and sacrifice his life for the
greater good just as every night show
just as he already did it by killing the
Mad King Jaime's riding north to fight
the army of the dead but then he'll
arrive back to the south to fight
against both the army of the Dead and
Cersei you might be a bit confused right
now and that's okay give me a moment
explain it
let me summarize Jamie's fate in the
final season until his very bittersweet
end in the beginning of season a Jim
still rides north through the Riverlands
there he reunites with Bronn and takes
charge of the lynnster forces that were
deployed in the Riverlands to ensure
peace he then leads his forces to
Winterfell where he arenas with his
brother Tyrion Brienne and all the
others Jaime will participate in a huge
battle for Winterfell in episode 3 in
which the living under John and Dana's
command will face a huge defeat how
Starks hereditary home will be destroyed
they will take severe casualties and
some of the main characters home in the
end a Jaime will survive
let me also highlight that there's a big
mystery surrounding the already infamous
3rd episode of the final season that
will be directed by the same guy who
directed the Battle of the bastards
there are few leaked photos are
supporting a possibility of the living
emerging victorious against the army of
the Dead
but it'll be sir senior graduate that
will destroy Winterfell basically in
this possibility Jon and Dana's forces
would face the army of the dead at
Winterfell and emerge victorious but in
massive casualties and no it doesn't
mean that living defeat in the night
king they justified it his current army
while his for me a new stronger and
larger army in the far south we all
thought that great 4 will be fought in
the north on the front defined by the
advancing army of the dead and partly we
are correct the north will face a
hundred thousand strong army of whites
led by the White Walkers by the night
King will not be there he will fly
Zairian to the far south across
Sylvester us and we'll raise a
does the entire continent will be facing
a horde of whites overnight now you
might be wondering how is this event
confirmed but give me a few moments
explained to you while prophecies in
gaming journals don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do
involve brains vision of the exploding
wildfire already came true in season six
there are two more visions from the
future they're yet to come true it's the
shadow of a dragon flying over King's
Landing and the one image brain sees
King's Landing in winter with an empty
throne room that has its roof blown off
at first glance this would imply that
Danny doesn't a preaching and taking
over King's Landing eventually but the
crumbled building the Red Keep and burnt
houses with the wintry background are of
the major importance then he would not
destroy the red cape in magenta on his
nor would she burn down houses for
innocent people live as proven in
numerous season seven scenes the damage
done to the Red Keep and to the house is
however is consistent with something
that Danish dragons would be able to do
the main suspect being her dead dragon
Masseria this brains vision Spanish
Danny had as well along with leaked
photos in which we can see that big
portion of King's Landing will at some
point be burned down pretty much confirm
my statement that night King will fly
with Aaron to the far south and raise
the dead across solo Westeros
but the leader White Walkers is forming
an army across ala Westeros his current
army that has in season seven finale
finally crossed it and Northville in the
season a premier hit and destroyed
castles of how sombre and how scarce
stark just as John in the season 7
premiere said they would if the ball
falls
basically the night king will create a
huge army in the south while sacrificing
his current arm in the north anyways
after the battle is over after the
living has gone against a hundred
thousand strong army of the Dead at that
very moment urine appears to the
Ironborn the Lancers sanded the golden
company he's been wearing for the battle
between the living and the dead to end
his there answers his orders to kill
what's left of the veining army you're
an attacking Winterfell once the battle
between living in the dead ends to kill
what's left of the victorious parties
coming as a huge surprise but at the
same time it's also kind of been
confirmed by League Forks in these
leaked photos that were taken home
interval set we can see the dead are
important that would be gross casualties
in this battle at Winterfell there's
even a leaked photo jam being taken
hostage to King's Landing supporting
this possibility even more as it seems
soon managed to imprison John
additionally this team will take place
in episode 4 as the director that
episode was seen on set
there is just one episode after the huge
battle for Winterfell so for News
possibility of urine Teyana hostage even
more hetero this turn of events might
not be that big of a surprise inserts
yourself said that she's going to use
urine graduate the golden company and
her armies to attack the victorious army
after the
though however one is turn either dead
or delivering themselves will destroy
Winterfell but Jamie as well as most of
the main characters will not face their
end just yet
now we're coming to the long-anticipated
Circe's downfall in death they'll be
caused by her becoming the met queen
but unfortunately sir still not the end
for herself but for Jamie as well upon
suffering the tremendous defeat at
Winterfell and upon losing Jon Snow to
yearn and Cersei Dany and the crew will
retreat south through the Riverland
sword avail however devil then learned
that the knight King has formed an even
bigger army of the dead in the South
brain starkville informed them that the
nineteen is marching his new army on
King's Landing King's Landing is the
largest city with a population of 1
million people and therefore they cannot
allow the knight King to take it because
it would mean the end for living all the
main characters being an insulating at
some point on the final season has been
confirmed by the leaked photos as well
even though the entire living side is
coming to Circe's aid she's preparing a
chat for them Circe intends to have all
her enemies both the living and the dead
to fight on streets of King's Landing
while she would use wildfire to burn
them all
Circe his plan is to wait in the red
cape for the army of the Dead to bridge
the city walls and for the great battle
to take place inside a capital Cersei
wouldn't burn all our enemies the living
and the dead using wildfire well sir she
managed to pull it out and burn everyone
down
even though burned King's Landing set
would seem to support this theory the
answer is no the Wildfire is not the
reason King's Landing set is being
burned down its dragon fire the show
build the King's Landing set mainly to
duel I power techniques meaning that
some parts of the capital will be burned
down by a dragon measuring on firing
game thrones is portrayed by live power
techniques basically stars is planned to
have the living and the dead fighting
style King's Landing will come true but
her burning them all with wildfire will
not who will stop her even though this
part is not confirmed by leaked photos I
think it's safe to say that the one to
stop star C from burning down into our
capital is Jaime Lannister Jamie already
did a huge sacrifice in order to save
hundreds of thousands of innocent lives
by killing the Mad King and has ever
since been called the King's lair to his
rotation however sir Steven now intend
to do the same through the show we
learned that the Scourge Jaime carries
from his decision to kill King Aerys
Targaryen run deep and Jamie's a man
desperate to forge his own legacy not to
be remembered as the King's lair Jimmy
will do noble sacrifice once again but
this time he will not sacrifice his
honor this time it requires his life
Jamie's going to kill his sister once
she gives an order to Qyburn to as the
Mad King used to say burn them all Jaime
will sacrifice himself by killing Cersei
as the mountain will kill him
immediately
Jimmy will kill the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms once again but this time people
will not mock his name this time
everyone will know that Jaime Lannister
is the savior of the city and the only
reason they're alive his name will be
remembered as a hero and his great deed
will fulfill his empty pages in the
famous book of brothers his death will
probably be avenged by the Hound we
bring help how I see it happening is the
central gain and Brienne arriving at the
throne room just at the time to see the
mountains striking down Jaime the
countin battles the mountain in epical
game ball while Jaime dies in Britain's
arms how do you want to go this Jaime's
end might have been foreshadowed by Lady
Olenna Tyrell and her last words but
your sister has done things I was
incapable of imagining you love her you
really do love her you she'll be the end
of you possibly the last Lannister at
this point Tyrion is also going to die
his death has been confirmed by the same
source that leaked the entire season 7
the source is freaky doctor whose
channel you can visit by clicking the
link in the description down below last
year this guy shared the entire season 7
plot claiming it's legit leaks and as
most of you know it turned out accurate
Tyrion will apparently be judged the
dragon beta shortly after executed
details freaky doctor says that in the
charge of our trial lizard that was
sievert accompanying with old Starks
sensory and brain they're also similarly
brain tart Robin Arryn and two new
characters one of them wearing a golden
armor grave army the unsullied will also
be there with a group of the unsullied
guarding Tyrion Lannister Tyrion is
being on trial for betraying Daniel's
family
freaky doctor says that bran Stark will
use his greenside powers during this
trial and take us back to the first
season bran recalls something Turner
said to his mother Catelyn Stark in the
first season
it's Tyrion statement that he would
never bet against his family there's
another thing we know Jaron will say
they deserve it implying that the people
of King's Landing deserve to die Tyrion
is full of anger the more dramatic
moment of the trial will be Tyrion
falling on his knees in the middle of a
speech
dragged down by his actions he will also
not be able to ask for a child by combat
Fricke doctor doesn't know how to he'll
be executed because unlike the trial his
death was not filmed in Seville but in
the studio he also mentions that there
will not be much of a snow at the dragon
pit as most of it already melted down at
this point of the season meaning that
winter is most likely over by the time
Tyrion is being under trial
during the trailer is being judged for
it in a game of trans finale
he's betrayed a knee in his side of its
family but how is it possible one may
ask well in truth it's all be happening
before our eyes
turns been fighting for Housley insert
or the entire season 7 and we've all
witnessed it because of Tyrion in his
warplanes Dany has lost most of her
allies and her strength has drastically
decreased due to Tyrion and his planes
Dany has lost Dorne and the Aran Islands
- urine and Cersei during a strategy to
take history Rock was a disaster as well
the unsullied of the fortress but the
fortress was severely undermanned as
most of the Lannister garrison has left
the castle and attacked Highgarden
destroying another than easily and
taking all the food and gold Tyrion was
basically at varied by his brother Jaime
Lannister all these turns plains
resulted with the food and the gold
being unprotected and basically for
Cersei to take it which she did Tyrion
explains also resulted it an opportunity
for Cersei to wipe out most of the
initial ice which she did as well the
final war plenty ran head for Dany was
to bring the dead to Cersei Lannister -
in her sport this resulted with the
death of a dragon and which hers is
still not willing to support the living
is it possible that earrings being
outsmarted by Cersei and Jaime even
though he'd said to be the smartest
Lannister is it a coincidence that all
Terence plans made more damage than good
for Dany
Tyrion haasvelt intellect and keen mind
for strategy was seemingly without peer
righted Westeros says then his hand with
one of the greatest armies that Westeros
has ever seen if he wanted to Tyrion
could have secured the throne for Dany
and make her army stronger than ever but
he did just the opposite and with the
purpose to make his family the most
powerful once again long story short the
only way for Cersei and Jaime to appear
as the winning side against desserts
would be if Tyrion was still fighting
for his family if he decided to spare
their lives
did he really believe Cersei when she
said that she wasn't helped north to aid
a living in the great war against the
night king the answer is no as a matter
of fact Cersei and Tyrion made together
this decision let me explain how they
took place in the season 7 finale is
opening moments Johnston was presented
with an opportunity to earn a promise of
peace from Cersei instead chooses to
remain loyal to Dani Tyrion in
particular was upset with Jon explaining
that sometimes there's a value in
telling someone you'll give them what
they want even if you do not plan on
actual dings Oh which is exactly Tyrion
and Cersei did later in the episode it
Cersei promising to aid them in the
great war throughout the meeting Tyrion
even confessed that his don't prove any
House Lannister from falling
bring her here with her patent-holder
whom you've convinced about down before
I know I was working towards the same
goal
the gong you've work towards your entire
Jessie I didn't know option at this
family I am the warden preventing that
from happening
Daenerys didn't want to debate and
negotiate she didn't want to bring you
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise I
don't want to destroy our family I never
have dearly smart and all the plans he
made he stole through them and he saw
the outcome everything he did hit the
river the purpose and that's to prevent
House Lannister from falling to make it
stronger anyways after professing his
love for services this is children and
realizing his sister was pregnant even
softened just before the camera cuts
away from the scene altogether the next
time we see two characters is during the
return to the dragon pit Cersei subtly
willing to help John and Danny in their
battle against the White Walkers so to
be clear Tyrion said to read people and
their intention as easily as he reads
books which has been proven right
multiple times throughout the show but
he fails to read her Cersei he fails to
read her sources intention and believes
her civil send help
Tyrion and Cersei most likely made a
deal under meeting exactly when the
camera cut away and it's Tyrion who told
her story with John and Danny and who
promised them to help in the wars to
come
Jenna's new plan is to put Cersei and
Jaime child on the Iron Throne
Tyrion cut a deal with Cersei you know
she was not going to go north and he
told her to lie about it basically
Tyrion works for the best of his family
and it will most likely be exposed by
brain and his visions what we know for
sure is that Tyrion will have a trial
for his treason or Dany and he will die
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace